la guerra empieza el 24 de febrero con
una ofensiva rusa en el norte los
objetivos la capital kiev y jarquín la
segunda ciudad del país en los primeros
días el crimen también se moviliza en el
sur contra el puerto de mariupol donde
los rusos organizan un sitio después la
ciudad de gerzón que hay rápidamente sin
embargo en el oeste la contraofensiva
ucraniana defende mykolaiv e impide a
los rusos avanzar hacia the sun
a mediados de marzo y el siguiente la
toma de la urbe principal acaba siendo
mucho más difícil de lo que moscú
imaginaba y no llega a concretarse
puestos ucranianos resisten en el norte
con contra ofensivas eficaces hasta
retomar control de las regiones
alrededor de la capital el 2 de abril
rusia se retira del norte del país y
empieza a concentrar sus esfuerzos en el
sur y el este de ucrania mariupol sigue
sufriendo bombardeos intensos y si cae
en manos rusas en las últimas semanas
las contraofensivas ucranianas han
alejado a las fuerzas rusas de jarquín
pero en mariupol tras dos meses de feroz
resistencia ucraniana los rusos
finalmente logran controlar la
estratégica ciudad portuaria y la planta
metalúrgica de as hostal los rusos ahora
concentran sus esfuerzos en el donbass
en las regiones de lugansk y túnez el
presidente ucraniano ha dicho este lunes
que las próximas semanas serán difíciles
para su país